5 24 on your Wednesday morning we're for
sure going to be talking about this a
lot more in our regular traffic reports
in a week or so but I wanted to make
sure you don't miss this update on those
freeway HOV lanes in Las Vegas
has the Nevada Department of
transportation's huge project neon was
wrapping up on I-15 around the spaghetti
Bowl three years ago what had been Rush
Hour only HOV or carpool lanes became a
widely criticized 24 7 operation and as
we reported on driving you crazy back in
June of this year scheduled to run
through early August traffic data
sensors are going to be put in at 17
freeway locations counting vehicles and
the number of people inside them to
determine if operating hours could or
should change well on Monday of this
week ndot director Christina swallow
said that based on preliminary data from
that study HOV lanes are going to be
switching from 24 7 to 5 a.m to 10 p.m
meaning that between 10 pm and 5 a.m HOV
lanes will be regular travel lanes for
anyone to use
so this is scheduled to start Monday
October 24th but even the new seven day
a week hours they're subject to change
indot says over the next 18 months these
so-called pilot hours are going to be
reviewed to see about maybe more
adjustments including maybe going back
to 24 7 operation buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com